Film Courage: You talk about the screenwriting process?
So Daved Wilkins had this idea yeah and you two
were bouncing ideas off of each other
but how did the actual screenplay
process work out? Gavin Michael Booth, Writer/Director/Producer: Daved and I would try
to get together in person as often as
possible I'm a stickler for outlining
the story before you start writing
writing dialogue so a lot of it was just
the painstaking and this this because we
have two sides of the story we have to
make sure that there's something
interesting happening on both sides of
the screen at the same time and you know
it's interesting because for an audience
perspective they can see say for example
there's a moments not a big spoiler but
like Scott lies and says that he stopped
drinking isn't gonna have anything else
to drink so she feels relieved and the
things are going the right way but what
the audience can see is that's not the
case so we're sort of always ahead of
the game we want to sort of give it that
perspective but also finding ways where
just the the synergy of if she's sitting
in the darkness or talking about a dark
story then he's out on the balcony and
the light just ways to keep a story
interesting that would translate
visually when you're never cutting and
can't go back and cut anything because
real time that's that's it you know
you're done you know we have no hidden
cuts there's there's nothing like that
so a lot of it was just figuring out the
structure of how to do the story but
also having a story where we're gonna
have one phone call for the entire time
the dynamics of that the reveals of
informations the sort of like twists or
shocks or turns just just pacing that I
was the agonizing part and then you know
Daved and I both really enjoy writing
the dialogue and Daved I think some of
the most beautiful dialogue he's written
to date out of anything I've read is in
this script and you know a lot of that
was he he was always going to place God
in the movie you know he's the actor in
the film as well so I think he was able
to also cater writing that would suit
his skill set and and really help draw
the best of his acting talents and the
character and then once we knew that
Sarah Booth was going to play Beth I
also you know I had a great chance to
work with her a handful of times I've
seen her on stage and one-act plays that
are you know two hours on stage with no
scene breaks I just knew that we could
also throw a lot of you
having dialogue at her that she'd be
able to do it and yeah we try to meet as
much as possible we used the software
writers duet to write the script writers
do what operates similar to Google Docs
where if you have multiple people on it
even if we're not together we can see
every change word by word just appears
in the document so I'm sitting looking
at the screen and Daved's writing I can
see what's being changed as you know
even if we're working remotely and then
what was neat was we were able to since
it was Daved and Sarah and we're all
friends or or lives you know Sarah's my
wife so we live together it's easy to
schedule a rehearsal and we would
actually get together read through
portions of the script we were able to
sort of like adapt based on hearing it
out loud and then leading up to the
actual we were writing the film right
into the film production because there's
also we always knew there'd be what we
call like an accordion effect where
until we could actually rehearse it on
set and like okay well it says that
Scott walks from the bar to his
apartment is that going to be seven
minutes long is that gonna be 12 minutes
long is that three minutes long based on
the locations we had we knew that we
probably have to add or remove dialogue
to get it in the sort of timeframe that
we wanted to finish film to be so every
day that we rehearse things we would
change things remove things and more and
we were able to sort of film every
rehearsal and see how it so sort of a
living breathing script right up until
even the first couple takes versus the
last takes that there are changes to the
to the story and the characters that
happen so a little different than
anything else we'd written but what what
ended up being really neat was Sarah had
gone to Montreal to shoot a project
Daved was in LA and I was in Windsor [Ontario, Canada]
prepping things for the movie and
working on a couple music videos in
Ontario so we would do our rehearsals
over the phone so then as actors we're
already doing what they were gonna have
to do on screen and I was able to just
kind of listen to the phone call as the
director of one of the writers and make
notes and say this is boring this
doesn't work this this is this is
mumbling and confusing and not clear so
sort of that that busyness benefit in
the script being able to sort of
rehearse it the way it was going to be
performed and you shot the film in
Canada he said shot the film my home
city and when
Ontario Canada so anybody who's seen the
film or has a chance the bridge in the
background it is not Brooklyn or New
York it is it is Detroit Michigan is the
Ambassador Bridge that connects the
countries might you know we were we our
goal with this film was to make it super
micro budget so that we wouldn't be out
of pocket we also end up making
independent film like the landscapes
changing there's no more blockbuster
there's barely a DVD and a home video
market anymore so you have to make your
movies that don't have big stars in them
you have to make them for a fraction of
the budget if you want to be successful
in recruiting money at the end of the
day so having said all that shooting at
home I knew you know the college we
worked at a deal with the college that
we filmed in because in the script the
character of Beth is the night janitor
at a college but we had this beautiful
College building that we had full access
to every day to rehearse and lights and
prep and shoot the movie in and they
baden essentially sponsored the movie
and even had some of their students come
help on Senate and help behind the
scenes which was phenomenal the film
score was recorded live in a single take
and that was done at the college's
beautiful theater the Chrysler theater
in Windsor again they they helped us we
we did that event as a student event
where high school students could come
and watch the making of of a score and
learn about how film music is created so
my home city is always not a lot of
filmmaking happens there so it's
exciting we always try to involve the
students and the people we had
restaurants little restaurants that
sponsored us and hotels that kind of
steals really out-of-town cast and crew
so the limited funds we did have we
could put on the screen and in the
production value and not don't worry
about if we shot it in LA I think the
price would be quadrupled with the
permits and and you know if I need to
close entire streets to walk from a bar
to a part of going it just I don't think
it would have happened you know we had
this high-rise it but it's just
everything worked out perfect said the
bar we filmed in is my favorite bar back
home for move my friend Matt that owns
the bar is also an actor so he plays the
bartender and the bar owner in the movie
there was just so much sort of perfect
synergy to tissued it there
can't imagine us having done it at one
point I toss her for about five and a
half seconds I said what are we shot one
side in LA one side in Windsor and then
we truly have this phone call that's
across you know even the border and in
everybody said no that's too fast we
don't have maybe one day when we have
the money we'll do something bigger
you